就不给他
我跟你说
现在开始要牌子的了
知道吧
就是以前的时候
小学的时候不懂
我在那冲的
我在那一次
就是说冲
给他买鞋子
冲的钱到现在还有了
就是买的也
也一百五
一百五六一双
知道吧
现在上初中了
不要了
来腰后面带松紧的
腰后面带松紧的
你来这一款是一个M码
年七十八
那就不给
给了他也不会穿的
浪费钱
对
来直筒裤
腰式半腰松紧
两边有鞋纱兜
屁股后面有直纱口袋
他说妈妈一共买的鞋
我同学都说是
是假的
不愿意了
又在那个
那个上远
养男孩是这样的
初中就开始讲究了
是不是
腰围六十六十
可以拉到七十四来
腿尾的话
一二二一二六
一二二一二六来
现在都是在那个某得某某物上面买来
当场三十八
裤长一一零零裤长一零零
拿这种裤子
谁要谁来过
三十九三十九空零
三十九三十九
谁要谁来扣个零
来喜欢的姐姐就不三十九空零
来这一款来给我们看一下这个圆领圆领全棉的全棉的
前面在刺绣字母的前面在刺绣字母圆领全棉有蓝色
有这个粉色啊
有蓝色
有这个粉色
这个是棉一百啊
男生女生都可以穿最小S最大是两个加来胸围一百一百零六来长度的话
七十三来
来这款谁要十九十九扣一扣一呀
来喜欢的姐姐就不十九十九扣一扣一呀
十九扣一呀
来这一款来给把我们看一下均码均码的啊
面料锯纸啊
F码面料锯纸的直等裤咖色的啊
没有口袋腰后面是松紧腰直等裤面料锯纸面料锯纸的来腰围六十四可以拉到
八十六腿胃
一一六可以拉伸了
一二二一一六一二二当场是三十六裤长是九十八来这套裤子谁要三十九三十九扣八扣八来喜欢的姐姐
又不三十九扣个八
三十九谁呀
谁来扣个吧
来这个连衣裙
条纹的剪刀领
剪刀领腰式松紧腰
面料锯纸的
来这个连衣裙连衣裙条纹条纹
看一下长袖啊
这个是来胸围
胸围一百一百零二
腰围七十
可以拉到八十四
七十八十四来裙长
一二七裙长一二七
来这个裙子谁要
原价是五十九的
来现在二十九
二十九扣个七
二十九二十九
谁要谁来扣个七
扣七扣七
二十九扣个七
哇这个是MAK家的
MAK家的
V领V领带花边的
小裤子
有裤衙有裤衙小裤
V领V领带花边的
哦圆领
圆领带花边的啊
MAK家的这个
腰上少腰带
领子上面少了一个裤子
这个啊
想想可以可以咱们姐
小姐姐们配一粒裤子
你们回家捧一下
这个啊
他们家吊牌价都是要一万多的
一万五六
一万四五这样子啊
胸围九十二
一二零二九十二一二二
长度七十八长度七十八
来这一款谁要谁来扣
谁要谁来扣二十九
二十九扣零
原来是五十九的
二十九二十九
谁要谁来扣零
MAK家的啊
MAK家的姐妹们出了
二十九二十九扣零
这个没标了
这个没有标了
面料非常舒服
面料非常舒服啊
扣零
这个都是用的裙子
裙子里面的内装
哎哟
这个有洞
有啥宝贝没有
这什么管道
所以说
这就是用了个辅助形式了
不要 outcomes
太吗
这就是一个
一些
你 choses
Do the
want to
show
U
what
tell
you
what
to
who
what
to
tell
what
show
to
how
来这个翻领翻领
有弧度的前面短后面长
前面短一点后面长一点
面料锯纸
面料锯纸的
来来我们来量一下
胸围胸围
长度前面70后面73
来这款谁要谁来扣29
29扣个2
2929扣个2
里边要穿个小裹胸的
这种谁要谁来扣
2929扣2扣2
来喜欢的姐姐
就扣29扣个2
来这个马甲灰色的
来灰色这个马甲
有裤有裤牙
来这一款灰色的这个马甲
来两边有直插口袋
军马军
哦不对
这个是锯纸的啊
面料锯纸
面料锯纸的灰色马甲
我看一下这个是什么马
什么马
没标了
没有标了
只有一个领子上面
只有一个品牌标
只有一个这个牌
来
胸围胸围
来长度65
长度65
来这个谁要29
29扣个2
2929扣个2
扣个2
来喜欢的姐姐就扣29扣个2
这个灰色的马甲
来29扣个2
29扣个2
来这一款打底衫
黑色的
领子是这样的
后面有隐形拉链的
后面是有隐形拉链的
它这个领口看到吗
皱皱的
它的袖口也是皱皱的
领口皱皱
袖口也是皱皱的
看到了吗
来这一款我们来量一下
你们听一下这个打底穿
后面有隐形拉链的
来这一款是
巨指77
人棉19
圈指4%
来胸围90
90 96
长度68
来这一款谁要谁来扣29
29扣个8
29 29
咱们谁要谁来扣个8姐妹们
冲了冲了冲了
29扣8
好你等我你来啦
好的
来
下午好
来391
下午好姐们
来391321好
谢谢啊
好看的
这个咱穿到里边配衣服或者你单穿都好看
帅帅的酷酷的感觉
谢谢
给你送个小礼物
小口罩给你
拉这个小吊带
小美贝一样的这个小吊带
来这个是这个牌子的
M码
面料
锯纸的面料锯纸
这个来我给大家
本来咱这个是卖29的啊
这个太短了
咱们这个就是
有的叠穿单穿这个我给你们放福利便宜点好吧
这本来卖29的腰后面后面的带松紧的
后面带松紧的M码面料锯纸啊
M码面料锯纸来胸围平铺76
但是可以拉到88
其实有88腰围的话是78
68腰围是68
来这个谁要9块
9块扣零
谁要谁来个9块扣零
来这个咱们当个小美贝穿或者你单穿叠穿配衣服都可以了啊
9块9块扣零
非常好看
9块9块扣个小零
扣零扣零
来这个衣服这里有个小洞洞
很小的一个洞洞看到能看到吗
在这个贴标的这个上面看有一个小洞洞
看到了不来这一款滑滑的这个面料滑滑的可以防晒
可以外搭在这个就在这个位置啊
在这个位置来这一款面料锯纸的面料锯纸的来这款咱们来量一下
你们听下这个外套两边有口袋啊
两边有口袋
两边有口袋来胸围
胸围130来长度的话是62来这个谁要9块9块扣二9块9块谁要谁来扣个二来喜欢的姐姐去扣9元9元谁要谁来扣个二扣二扣二
9块9块扣二扣二
来这个灰色的前微后微前微后微灰色人年三十五聚值六十五啊
人年三十五聚值六十五
他这个是个有一点点蝙蝠袖蝙蝠袖的感觉啊
他这个有条纹
有这个一色的灰的啊
有条纹有灰色的来这一款咱们来量一下胸围122126122可以拉伸到126来长度长度
来衣服的
来咱们来量一下啊
前面61后面66
来这个谁要9块扣3
9块9块扣3
年35去值65
谁要谁来扣9块扣3
9块扣3
来喜欢的小姐姐就扣9块9块扣3
啊你懂我
有个裤子很好看的
你要不要看一下
威拉
你懂我
我自留的那个裤子
我自留的那个裤子老好看了
直播间的姐姐给我说好看
我才留的
我买了我也得
我也得赔给你
有个牛仔裤威拉的
我自留了
给你看看啊
那个裤子我觉得你穿应该好看
但是不知道你大不大
来392
给你看看
常规短袖的你OK
来392
392牛仔裤威拉的你喜欢吗
要不要给你看一下
那个裤子好看
颜色颜色
你看你喜欢不
反正我一眼就看上了喜欢了
然后我一穿
他们都说好看
然后我就自留了
笑死我了
给你看看啊
给你看看
这个威拉的
威拉的这个裤子
腰是这样子的
看到了吗
到肚脐眼
然后两边有口袋
这前面是有三粒裤
有三粒裤有弹力的
威拉的这个裤子
他们说显瘦
来腰尾的话
平铺64 64
但也可以拉伸到80
他有弹力
腿尾的话是92
可以拉伸到192 100啊
来当场的话是33
裤长的话是104
拉这个裤子谁要39
扣个6啊
非常好看的一款
威拉裤威拉裤
我那天穿有个小姐姐要
说是一个新粉
但是当时的时候没找到
然后这又出来一条
39谁要谁扣6哦
谁要谁去扣个6哦
还有啥宝贝
来这个灰色的这款
透极衫燕麦色吧
也可以说是个燕麦色
前面有拉链啊
单层单层
单层单层M码
面料写的句子
前面有拉链有拉链的
这款来胸围
胸围
胸围108 112
108 112
长度65
来这款谁要19 19扣1
19 19扣1
前面有两边有口袋
两边有口袋的这款透极衫
可以防晒可以外搭
19 19扣1扣1啊
来这一款
这一款S